foreign
UTC so um hello everyone and uh welcome
to the whisper fine tuning event
um we're very happy to have all of you
here and uh we hope we hope you're very
excited to be participating in the event
um so this talk uh we're just going to
have a brief introduction to the event
give you a bit of information as to how
the event is going to run and point you
in the direction of resources so you
know where to look for training scripts
how you can get compute allocation how
you can fine tune your model and where
you can go for help
um so we'll now dive in and take a look
through what is the golden document for
this event which is um which is the
readme document
and you can find this on the um
community events repository under
hugging face community events so we'll
share a link to this in the Discord
Channel and it's been posted uh several
times uh so this is your One-Stop place
for obtaining all the information that
you need for the whisper fine tuning
event
um so we'll briefly go through the
pertinent points on this readme and then
we'll leave some time at the end for
questions and uh we'll explore some of
the things that you can do
um to adapt the scripts for your
language and some of the things that you
can change to potentially get better
results
um so there's an introduction uh whisper
is a pre-trained model for speech
recognition and it was published very
recently back in September by authors
from openai and the standout feature of
whisper is the fact that it was
pre-trained on 680 000 hours of labeled
speech data so this is over an order of
magnitude more than previous systems
which were primarily trained on
unlabeled data so this is the this is
really the unique selling point of
whisper the fact that it's been
pre-trained on so much data and why is
that important for us uh well it means
that the model has a strong ability to
generalize to other data sets domains
and most crucially languages
because this 680 000 hour Corpus was
multilingual it means that whisper was
trained on 96 languages so whisper has a
lot of knowledge about not just English
ASR but also many many other languages
and we're going to use this when it
comes to fine-tuning so the idea is that
we take this whisper checkpoint the
pre-trained checkpoint and we're going
to fine-tune it for our language of
choice and hopefully improve the
performance further and so the goal of
this event is to bring everyone in the
community together for a two-week Sprint
to try and fine-tune whisper in the
languages of your choice so you as a
participant can choose the language that
you want to find Junior whisper in and
we're on hand to help you to try and
achieve the best results possible and we
think in this way we can hopefully
democratize speech recognition for
everyone
um so we'll be providing training
scripts notebooks blog posts talks such
as this one and compute when we can
um so you really should have everything
that you need to participate and we want
to make it as easy as possible for you
to participate and that being said feel
free to ask questions both in this talk
and on Discord uh we're really on hand
to help you
um so you're allowed to fine-tune your
system on whichever whatever training
data you want and we have included
pointers for fine-tuning a system on
data sets on the hiding face hub using
hiding face data sets but you can also
use your own data website data private
data sets and we've included pointers
for this in the training scripts as well
now the important thing to remember is
that the whisper models will be
evaluated on the test split of common
voice 11 in the participants chosen
language and what this means is that you
should not use the test bit of common
voice 11 or any other common voice
Corpus or addition for fine-tuning your
model this is the only data that is
prohibited for fine-tuning your system
in circumstances where there isn't data
for the common voice 11 or common voice
Corpus for your language will work with
you to devise a suitable training set or
suitable test set so that we can fairly
evaluate your system so if your language
isn't one of the ones in Converse 11
you're still fully welcome to
participate and we encourage you to do
so
uh now at the heart of this
um whilst we're framing it as a
competition uh this event is more about
uh working together as a community and
we really want to Foster an environment
where we can learn from each other work
together and uh ultimately enjoy
ourselves as we learn something new
um so we advise that you work together
and help each other and we encourage you
to seek those state-of-the-art results
um but we really want to work together
to help everyone and that's the sort of
environment that we want to Foster
uh now this is the crucial thing and if
there's one thing that you take away
from this introduction talk is that this
readme that we're presenting here that
you'll be linked to contains all the
information that you need for the event
um and we've stretched it so that you
can read through it section by section
and assimilate all the information that
you need for the event so we recommend
that you read this document once from
start to finish before you read any code
and so this will give you an idea of
where to look for relevant information
an idea of how the event is going to run
and you might have questions that are
answered later on in the document
uh so reiterate again but this is the
One-Stop place to get all the
information for the fine tuning event
and so in terms of dates uh today is the
2nd of December and we're kicking off
the event with the introduction talk
here the Sprint officially starts on the
5th of December uh on the same day we're
very lucky to have two fantastic
speakers
um from openai and meta AI who are going
to give talks on the whisper model and
the fox popularly data set and we
encourage you to join us for those talks
um the problems to be very exciting
uh the Sprint is going to take place for
two weeks so we'll finish on the 19th of
December and we hope to have the remote
the results announced uh by the end of
that week
um so this readme then dives into some
more intricate details such as uh how
you can launch a Lambda Cloud GPU
um
how you can then set up a python
environment
um
all the way through to data and
pre-processing which goes a little bit
deeper into the explanation I've just
given into the common voice data set
um
and then jumps into the main bit which
is how you can actually find tune
whisper
uh
at the end we've included some fun extra
bits which include
um how you can build a demo using your
model and some tips and tricks for how
you can explore some memory saving
Concepts
now the main thing to remember here is
that all the information you need is on
the document so
um we don't expect you to take
everything away in this talk but we'll
go through some of the main points
um
so firstly when it comes to using
compute
um the advice is to use your own GPU or
Google collab Pro or Pro Plus where
possible
um so if you have your own local GPU
that you can use to train uh we advise
that you use that and that just means
that everything will be faster to set up
if you have a Google collab Pro or Pro
Plus subscription
it's very much the case that you should
be able to fine-tune whisper on a Google
collab
um we advise that you don't use a
standard Google collab because the GPU
probably isn't powerful enough for very
long training runs and will limit you to
using the small model with the small
checkpoint with smaller check with
smaller batch sizes
[Music]
um in this section we've also included
the steps
um and so if you if you don't have
access to a local GPU or Google collab
that is an alternative
um so Lambda have been very uh kind in
offering GPU allocation for this event
um so we're partnering up with Lambda
and they will be able to provide you
with GPU compute if you don't have
access to a local GPU or a Google collab
uh now this readme details how you can
sign up with Lambda and create a cloud
instance so there is a limited amount of
compute available
um so the first 100 participants to
follow these steps and sign up with
Lambda will be guaranteed compute
resource and after that it will be on a
participant participant basis where
there is compute resource left
uh and so the main thing to bear in mind
is that to redeem uh GPU compute
allocation from Lambda you need to
follow these steps here for signing up
with Lambda and if you do this if you
follow these steps uh you'll receive 100
hours of 1x a100 usage and 100 hours of
180 100 usage is a very generous
allocation and uh so this should enable
you to complete between 5 and 10
training runs depending on the size of
the model that you use and how long you
decide to train the model for
um there are also then instructions for
creating a cloud instance and this is
very easy through the Lambda uh the
Lander webpage and this should be a
step-by-step guide that you can follow
through
um alongside the readme here will be
shortly uploading YouTube videos so you
can view each of these sections in
chunks and we don't want to bombard you
with all the information in this
introduction talk this is more just to
give you a pointers as to where you
should look for information but by the
end of the day this readme will also
have links to YouTube videos where you
can watch interactive uh setting up of
cloud instances and python environments
um so to reiterate if you if you need to
have if you are seeking Lambda GPU
computes uh we put you in the direction
of this readme and follow the
instructions for signing up
okay great so once you have your GPU set
up whether that be your local GPU and
Lambda Labs GPU or Google collab you can
go on to the steps for setting up an
environment and once again everything is
documented in the readme and the steps
are such that it shouldn't take you more
than five minutes to set up a python
environment once again we'll have a
video to talk you through this later but
essentially what we do is we set up our
Unix libraries and then our python
libraries in a virtual environment if
you're running into Google Play lab
everything is actually contained within
the Google collab notebook so you can
run everything from there
okay fantastic
um we'll just briefly covered the data
and pre-processing section so as
mentioned you can use whatever training
data you want you
uh your system will be evaluating on the
test of the common voice 11 data set and
you can use all training data barring
any test flip of the common voice data
set so this is something to bear in mind
that
whilst we're evaluating your models on
the common voice 11 data set you
shouldn't use any of the test data from
the common boys 10 987 or any other
Legacy common voice data set
um convoys does provide splits for
training and validation and we strongly
advise that you use these these are the
most this is the these this is the data
that is most in domain with the uh
evaluation data that we're using
uh for low resource languages it might
be the case that the training split
alone doesn't give you sufficient data
to fine-tune the model in which case you
can combine the training and validation
splits and this notation for combining
splits of train plus validation is
consistent for all the scripts and so
this is the API that data sets uses for
loading joint splits and it's the one
that we've also adopted
um so if you specify split a plus split
B like this then you can load a joint
split
um so there are several other data sets
that we advise that use if you need to
use if you want to explore larger Corpus
so these include the Vox property data
set multilingual Liberty speech and
flares and we include uh short
descriptions there if you're interested
in finding out more but your main Port
of Call should be the common voice
aladding data set
uh we'll shortly be releasing a blog
post that goes through all the data sets
from The hagenface Hub and also explains
the home face datasets library in case
you're new to it so we point you in this
direction if you want to find out more
okay
one of the unique aspects of the whisper
fine tuning event is that we're going to
be using streaming mode for downloading
our data and what this actually means is
that we're not ever going to be
downloading data to our device what
we'll do is load
load samples of our data at a time as we
iterate over our data set
so this basically bypasses the very
lengthy stages of fully downloading and
fully extracting a data set in the first
place so rather than doing that we just
we just stream samples of our data at a
time and the best way of thinking about
this is to compare how you would watch
TV so you've got two paradigms for doing
that you could either watch a download
you could either download a TV show to
your device or you could stream it and
when you download a TV show you download
that entire video and you save it to
your disk and that means that you can
watch it offline
um so while that means you've got it
offline you've got all of the data at
once it means that you have to go
through the process and the waiting time
of downloading all of that data and
preparing it to your device now the
other way that you could watch that TV
that same TV show is you could stream it
so you could go into a browser or you
could just boot up your TV and you could
stream the data so no point is sorry you
could stream the TV show so at no point
is that TV show downloaded to your TV
you just you just iterate over and load
that TV show in real time
we're going to use that same principle
here for training our machine learning
model rather than downloading the entire
data at the start we'll just stream
samples at a time and this means that
you won't need any
um disk space requirements and so you'll
be able to download data sets on the hug
and face Hub about to arbitrary size on
any device so if you want to say use the
English subset of comma voice 11 which
has 2 300 hours of data and requires
upwards of 200 gigabytes of disk space
that's fine
um you can do that on a collab you can
do it on your local GPU and it won't
require any disk space it won't have any
disk space requirements and um through
this it's actually possible to load up
samples of a data set straight away so
this code snippet here what we actually
do is we load the common voice data set
and stream mode and we print a sample
and you'll see that you can immediately
get access to the data set before you
would have had to wait until the whole
all dates that was downloaded and the
whole data set was pre-processed and
only then would you have access to the
first sample
here what we do is we just stream the
first sample and give it to you straight
away when you want the next sample
you'll just stream the next sample and
so it's as easy as that it's just like
streaming your your favorite TV series
and so we think this is a quite a neat
feature of of our fine-tuning scripts
and uh we're very interested to see
um the the feedback here
uh when it comes to pre-processing this
is a bit of a gray area in speech
recognition and so what we advise is
that you don't pre-process any of the
training data for common Voice or any of
the test data so this will leave the um
leave the training data with casing and
punctuation now why might we want to do
this well it means that our fine-tuned
whisper model will learn to predict
casing and punctuation
the model is also pre-trained to learn
casing and punctuation so it makes the
task of fine-tuning easier for the model
um however removing casing and
punctuation does benefit word aerate so
we have provided an option as such that
you can post process the transcriptions
and punctuate transcriptions and
predictions to remove casing and
punctuation when you compete your word
error rates and this will actually give
you better word error rate results but
your model will still learn to predict
casing and punctuation
okay uh
after the data and pre-processing we
went to the fun bit which is fine-tuning
whisper now there are three ways in
which you can execute the fine tuning
code we've provided a python script a
Jupiter notebook and a Google collab
um so we can actually go ahead and
um
open up the Jupiter notebook
so I've got it saved here already
um
foreign
and the readme has instructions on how
you should open up this Jupiter notebook
in your GPU device
so the notebook just starts with a brief
section on streaming mode which explains
the principle of streaming and then a
small introduction to the whisper model
and we point you in the direction of the
blog post fine tune whisper for
multilingual ASR with hunger-based
Transformers if you want to find out
more about what this notebook is
achieving
um and so this notebook goes through
similar steps uh to the blog post where
we load the data set uh we prepare a
processor and pre-process the data
um and then we train and evaluate our
model now the things to be aware of in
this notebook are how you can change the
notebook and adapt it for your language
um so the first thing would be
um when you load the data sets here we
know is the Spanish
subset of common voice so if you want to
load a different language you just need
to change the language identifier code
here so for Hindi this would be hi for
English it would be em or Spanish ES
uh the next thing that you need to do is
set a language when you load your
processor so here again we've got a
Spanish
um but you can set this to uh Hindi
again or Italian if you're doing Italian
whichever language you'll find tuning
off
um
so those will be two parameters that
you'll be changing at the start of the
script and then too closer to the end or
a set of parameters closed at the end
will be our Hydro parameters for
training so here this is where we can
set our training batch size our learning
rate and the number of warm-up steps
um our evaluations are batch size and
some other high parameters which are
explained more in the docs so the ones
that you will probably be interested in
changing are the training batch size the
learning rate and the maximum number of
steps
so you might need to reduce the training
batch size If you experience outer
Memories the learning rate might not be
set appropriately for your language or
the checkpoint that you're using
you might want to train for longer so
here we've given 5000 steps initiate
between five and ten hours depending on
your GPU if you want to if you think
you've got a very good Training
configuration and you want to train for
longer especially if you have a large
data set then you can bump this up to a
larger value so you can train for 10 000
or even 15 000 training steps
um within the readme we've actually got
recommendations for batch sizes as well
um so depending on your GPU device you
can follow these guidances for batch
sizes and um whilst they might not be
perfect these are very good starting
points so we point you in the direction
of these recommendations and again this
is all on the Ruby
and um once everything is defined you'll
just be able to start training
um and once training is finished you can
um you can push everything to the hug
and face hub and we advise that you
store everything on the hug and face Hub
because it means those full
reproducibility of your model and you
can also then go and share your model
with others
uh now the very nice thing about using
the hug and face Hub is that you can
quickly create demos
and share your models so we've actually
included a small tutorial for creating a
demo with your fine tune model and we
can actually just go over that quickly
here
um so what you need to do is um
head over to the space whisper event
whisper demo you can go over to these
three buttons here and duplicate the
space
uh you can then duplicate it under your
name and uh
I've already created it so I already
have that space duplicated
um and once you've duplicated it all you
have to do is change the checkpoint to
your fine tune checkpoint again here
I've got a checkpoint that I fine-tuned
you can save the save this file and
return and you'll have a demo that boots
up with your speech recognition model on
the Hub we're going to be adding some
more template demos so this is just a
little way in which you can quickly
build a demo
um and the last thing to draw your
attention to is what to do if you have
any issues so everything
um all the instructions for fine-tuning
whisper on a GPU uh using the python
script or notebook or on a Google collab
using the Google collab template are all
documented on the readme so you should
be able to go through this step by step
and learn how you can run these files
and as we said we'll be uploading
YouTube videos to make this even easier
but it could well be the case that you
experience issues with some of these
scripts or something doesn't work and in
this case we're on hand to help you out
so we encourage you to ask us and um
yeah we can work together to try and try
and solve your issues
um So within the readme uh we have
pointers for where you should go and ask
uh questions regarding to data sets
Transformers uh your training script uh
your Lambda GPU if you have one or any
other questions about the event
um so we really encourage you to ask
questions when you get stuck and as a
participant in the event uh we hope that
you'll be able to help others who who
have questions so just as a as a
reminder that we really are running this
event as a community event so we want
everyone to work together and we hope
that this is the best way in which we
can get everyone a fancy model that
they're proud of at the end
um so we've got the talks from
um openai and met AI Jong group Kim and
Chang and Wang on Monday uh so again
there are links to these talks and um we
also have a feedback form at the end so
at the end of the event at the end of
the event we'd uh we very much
appreciate you filling out the feedback
form and that'll just let us know which
bits went well and which bits um we can
improve on for next time
uh so I think that's what I wanted to
cover for the readme and the basis of
the event
um so we hope you're you're as excited
as we are to kick off the fine tuning
event and uh we hope that in two weeks
time uh we'll have a bunch of
state-of-the-art models and a bunch of
extremely performant whisper models in
many many different languages that you
can all be proud of
um so we can now do a quick q a
um for the remainder of the time that we
have
okay
okay maybe I can just quickly
um
ask the questions and and and and and
and we can
um take them one by one
um
so the first question is uh does the
training with punctuation and casing
also hold for uh diacritics
or or or or should be stripped them from
the uh data set
so it was
um I think it's
um in
the
um hold on a sec
um it's those special characters
um
which are used to
um
to denote accents if I'm not wrong
and so being generated yeah so the
general advice is that you should um so
the advice that we're giving you is that
you should not remove punctuation that
would change the meaning of a word
um so in the case of a full stop if you
remove a full stop from a sentence it
does not change the meaning of any words
whereas if you've got an apostrophe say
the word it's and you remove the
apostrophe between the T and the s that
would change the meaning of the word
from the shorthand for it is to it which
is a completely different word and so in
this case removing the punctuation has
changed the meaning of the word and so
the model would transcribe incorrect
transcriptions if you if you were to
remove apostrophes and so we have to use
the same premise when it comes to
deciding which characters we want to
remove
um so if you're going to be removing uh
punctuation or normalizing that is that
changes the meaning of a word that would
not be allowed and um the script that we
provided uh doesn't do that so you
should be very careful when you modify
it and if you've got any doubt
um we advise you to ask us and we will
seek to clarify it so it basically in
short
um you should not remove anything that
is going to change the meaning of the
word
right
um and then there's a question about um
is there a channel on Discord for all of
us to communicate uh maybe I can quickly
um talk about this
um so we we like within within Discord
if you go on
um role assignment Channel and click on
ML for audio over there then you'll have
access to all the audio channels where
we'll be running a point on all things
prints um and so on within that we have
a couple of channels so we have one for
Sprint announcements so wherein will be
um we'll be talking about um any and
every announcements in terms of
leaderboards or in terms of models or
data sets and so on and so forth um on
that channel and we have a discussions
channel uh wherein you can put up any
questions you have with respect to your
model training runs or data sets and so
on
um and an events channel so
um
just to summarize make sure that you go
to role assignment Channel and click on
ML for audio or audio roles so that
you're able to
um look at
um these channels and participate along
with
um another question is do you have any
tips on how to prevent hallucinations
with whisper
um
this person has experienced the model to
randomly generate text
um and and repeat the last generated
token
after their fine tuning runs
yes so the premise of Whispers that it
operates as an encoder decoder model and
it's the decoder side which is
responsible for generating the text
um and there's more on this in the blog
post so if you're interested in finding
out more about the whisper model so we
point you in the direction of the fine
tuning blog so if you want to control
the nature of the generated text
predictions then we're interested in the
models generate method and so there are
several things that we can do here so we
essentially want to modify the behavior
of the generate method and so they're a
generation hyper parameters that control
when the model terminates its
predictions what Criterion it uses to
terminate its predictions and the form
in which it generates these predictions
so those are all the things that you
want to explore if you find that your
model is hallucinating or generation
isn't performing the operation that
you'd expect it to so if anything works
out for Generation if that looks strange
then you want to explore the the models
dot generate method
and play where play around with the
hyper parameters there so you can do
things like um changing the length
penalty uh using beam search which will
give you potentially more accurate
predictions but the expense of being
much slower and you can also change
parameters like early stopping and and
your maximum generation length so that
would be the place to look if you find
that your model is hallucinating
fantastic
um then there is a question about from
your experience and maybe this can be
the last question because we're already
on time
um what is the
um from your experience how much GPU
memory does it does a large model take
and if you have any recommendations on
parameters for it
yeah so actually in my experience I've
done a bit of experimenting and so I've
been fine-tuning the small medium and
large checkpoints and uh I found that
the small type one is best if you want
to train your model on a lot of data so
if you have like a very large data set
and you want to get through as much of
that Corpus as possible it's very good
to use a small model and you can get
through a lot of training data and with
the media model training is going to be
slower and you're also going to need
quite a lot of data if you want to if
you want to fine tune this model because
it's obviously larger than the small
model
and you will get a bit of a performance
boost by using the medium model over the
small model even in low data settings
now the large model is quite a lot
larger than the media model it's
significantly larger and so
this will mean the training is a lot
slower and for a fixed amount of time
say you've got five hours you'll be able
to get through much much less of your
training data you'll have to use a very
low batch that per device batch size and
you have to use a lot of gradient
accumulation steps and the end result is
that if you have you know like a given
amount of time in which you want to
fine-tune your model generally the small
or medium checkpoints attain similar
performance to the large checkpoint or
even better and so it's actually very
difficult from a practitioner point of
view to use the large checkpoint and uh
so my advice would actually be to stick
with the smaller than medium checkpoint
the medium checkpoint attains very very
first performance the large one and
you'll just be able to train it much
quicker and much more easily it's much
more likely to fit on a GPU memory with
a reasonable batch size
there are tricks that you can do with
using the large model and there are some
pointers in the readme for how you can
save memory but I would advise that you
probably stick to the smaller than
medium checkpoint and these will get you
very good results
brilliant
um I think I think we can we can
probably take all the other questions in
Discord now and you know
um just just head over to Hash
discussions and you know we'll get to
those as soon as we can
um and yeah do do make sure to read me
yeah thanks thanks very much everyone
for joining in Asia Bibi mentioned the
readme is your One-Stop place to find
out everything about the event so we
went through everything quite quickly
here but if you want to find out more
about the training script how to set up
a GPU how it's going to work with Lambda
who we've partnered up with then head
over to the readme and check with that
out and yeah we'll be on hand on Discord
to answer the remainder of the questions
so thank you very much
thank you